dort gibt es jetzt schon im jahr 2021
exaflop supercomputer
china das mit seiner forschung und
entwicklung davon und hat jetzt wohl
still und heimlich zwei supercomputer
gebaut die bereits im exaflop bereich
laufen so meldet es zumindest eine
us-website die sich auf anonyme quellen
beruft diese exaflop supercomputer
könnten mehr als doppelt so schnell sein
als der aktuelle top 500 spitzenreiter
und der grund warum china sie
verschweigt bereitet sorgen kriegs 1 in
future jedes dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen
das ist wirklich ein chinesischer
doppelschlag ein starkes signal und vor
allem auch eine kampfansage an die usa
denn laut einer us website könnte china
gleich zwei exaflop superrechner gebaut
haben mitte des monats november 2021
könnte somit auf der top 500 liste
erstmals ein exascale system auftauchen
und damit eben gleich zwei exaflop super
rechner aus china genau wie die usa
europa und japan arbeitet auch china
bereits seit jahren an diesen exaflop
supercomputer pro sekunde schaffen sie
mehr als achtung eine trillion
gleitkomma berechnung in der fachsprache
ist von einem extra flops die räte das
weltweit der exascale wettrüsten läuft
also zu hochtouren auf was ist dran an
diesen meldungen und was genau hat china
da also gebaut die antworten auf diese
spannenden fragen gibt es jetzt hier bei
click solutions in future
supercomputer sind die giganten unter
den computern und ganz besonders
schnelle rechner der erste erfolgreiche
architekt eines supercomputers massiver
gray der cdc
6600 entworfen hatte 1964 sollte dieser
zehnmal so schnell errechnen können wie
die anderen computer dieser zeit seitdem
hat sich beim aufbau der supercomputer
viel getan nicht zu verwechseln
allerdings mit den quantencomputer diese
ermöglichen noch einmal eine weit
größere rechenleistung doch kann bislang
trotz intensiver forschung nicht
wirklich über das experimental stadium
hinaus kommen es gibt einfach keine
programme die etwas vernünftiges auf
quantencomputern berechnen können und so
sind supercomputer aus wissenschaft und
forschung immer noch nicht wegzudenken
sie spielen beispielsweise für
berechnung im bereich der astrophysik in
der klimaforschung in der
festkörperphysik und als zentralrechner
komplexer verteidigungssysteme eine
entscheidende rolle denn es sind
mittlerweile einfach unvorstellbar
enorme datenmengen die täglich in den
verschiedenen bereichen von forschung
und wissenschaft zusammen kommen egal ob
es um die strömung der atmosphäre geht
die suche nach neuen wirkstoffen oder
aber die entwicklung von kosmischen
strukturen denn supercomputer sind
tatsächlich in der lage selbst diese
komplexen prozesse zu simulieren dazu
der bioinformatiker jan kobel daten
verdoppeln sich in der wissenschaft alle
18 monate das ist die weltweite
datenlage in der wissenschaft in jedem
feld das ist auch ein trend der sich
seit über zehn jahren ständig fortsetzt
ohne big data können wir eigentlich gar
keine komplexe geologie mehr betreiben
selbst kleine labore erzeugen daten im
großen stil und brauchen heutzutage
computer und so sind
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weltweit damit beschäftigt immer
schnellere und leistungsfähigere
supercomputer zu bauen auch deutschland
ist mit am start und der schnellste
supercomputer europas steht in nordrhein
westfalen nach angaben der fachleute
erreicht jubel supercomputer in jülich
85 petaflops das heißt also dass er
achtung 85 milliarden rechenoperationen
pro sekunde durch führt das entspricht
tatsächlich der rechenleistung von mehr
als 300.000 modernen computer jewels ist
in der lage innerhalb eines codes
dynamisch auf normale computer chips cpu
s und auf grafik chips gpu
zurückzugreifen kann somit die rechnung
optimieren vor allem das neue poster
modul ist erwähnenswert ist umfasst
knapp 45.000 cpu kerne und rund 12
millionen sogenannter cuda kerne f b 64
auf seine grafikprozessoren eine
bestimmte programmiert technik macht es
möglich dass die grafikprozessoren teile
der cp rechenarbeit übernehmen im
vergleich zu herkömmlichen prozessorkern
kann jubelt so vor allem bei massiv
parallele arbeiten signifikant schneller
sei trotzdem im vergleich zu den us
amerikanischen supercomputern ist das
eine übersichtliche leistung der sierra
schafft 100 27 petaflops und der summit
mehr als 200 1 petaflops 1 petaflops ist
dabei ein tausendstel eines extra flops
außerdem bauen die usa derzeit die
beiden exaflop systeme frontier und el
capitano diese sollen zeitnah ihren
betrieb aufnehmen in deutschland wie man
in drei jahren 2024 mit dem ersten
exascale rechner an den start gehen dass
deutschland auch einen exaflop
supercomputer bekommen soll hatte die
europäische union im sommer 2021
beschlossen diese sollen dann den us
amerikanischen und chinesischen system
ebenbürtig ist ein doch china scheint
schon deutlich weiter als man bisher
angenommen hatte schon seit jahren
arbeitet man hier an supercomputern die
mehr als eine trillion gleitkomma
berechnungen pro sekunde schaffen also
ein extra floss der begriff flops ist
englisch und steht für floating point
operations also übersetzt etwa soviel
wie gleitkommazahlen operationen damit
kann man also die leistung eines
computers messen wenn man es ganz
vereinfacht sagen will computer rechnen
anders als wir menschen eben nicht mit
zahlen im dezimalsystem stattdessen
können sie nur zwei zustände
unterscheiden eben 1 oder 0 wie man es
in der mathematik sagt die rede ist vom
sogenannten binärsystem die zahl 14
wandelt der computer also um in den
binärcode 1 1 1 0 so dass die prozesse
und die werte dann verarbeiten können
das ganze würde natürlich deutlich
schwieriger wenn es um sehr große zahlen
geht dann wird der wert zerlegt und zwar
in einen speziellen ausdruck mit
exponent hierbei handelt es sich dann um
die gleitkommazahlen statt einer million
370.000 heißt es dann
1,37 mal 10 hoch 6 wenn zwei
gleitkommazahlen addiert oder
multipliziert werden bezeichnen
fachleute das als flop die ausgeführte
rechnung pro sekunde hat also die
einheit flops und macht somit möglich
die leistung von supercomputern zu
vergleichen eine top 500 liste wird
einmal im jahr in den usa veröffentlicht
und zwar bei der supercomputer konferenz
der association for computing machinery
und der
computer society hierbei werden die
systeme in hinblick auf ihre
rechenleistung das betriebssystem ihre
hardware kennzahlen und andere faktoren
verglichen bisher ist der japanische
foucault supercomputer der spitzenreiter
mit 442 peter fox mitte des monats
november 2021 könnte hier also dann
erstmals ein exascale system auftauchen
und gleich zwei chinesische
flops superrechner das meldet die us
website the next plattform und beruft
sich dabei auf anonyme quellen demnach
handelt es sich bei beiden systemen um
nachfolger der fünfhunderter
spitzenreiter laut der website haben die
beiden neu entwickelten exaflop
supercomputer möglicherweise bereits vor
monaten die extra flops schallmauer
durchbrochen bereits im märz hatten
beide rechner theoretisch 1,3 extra
flops bei doppelter genauigkeit erreicht
eines der beiden systeme ist ein
nachfolger des aktuellen sun bright der
über eine theoretische rechenleistung
von
125,4 petaflops und 93 petaflops im
linpack benchmark verfügt und somit noch
immer auf dem vierten platz liegt der
linpack benchmark stammt übrigens von
einem der macher der top500-liste und
dient somit als messlatte für die
offizielle top 500 rangliste sunway hat
den neuesten informationen der us
website zufolge wohl auch den nachfolger
gebaut sein name oceanwide hierbei haben
die entwicklerinnen und entwickler wohl
risc prozessoren genutzt die in china
entwickelt wurden das sind chips mit
einem reduzierten befehlssatz die chips
möglicherweise als sw 52020 bezeichnen
könnten doppelt so viele computer
prozessor element c ps aufweisen und
doppelt so breite vector einheiten
vereinfacht ausgedrückt sie können zum
einen doppelt so viele aufgaben
durchrechnen und zum anderen die
doppelte datenmenge verarbeiten gebaut
wurde dieser exaflop supercomputer vom
national research centre auf computer
engineering and technology and sea
breeze das zweite exascale system stammt
von der national university of defense
technology judith seine bezeichnung t3
einen nachfolger also das tier 2 a der
damals als schnellster computer weltweit
gehalt auch dieser supercomputer soll
theoretisch 1,3 exaflop schaffen spannen
hierbei beide exaflop supercomputer
basieren auf der grundlage von zwei
unterschiedlichen architektur die aber
beide chinesische art sind sowohl die
rechen beschleuniger als auch die
prozessoren beider systeme wurden in
china selbst entwickelt klar ist dass
mehrere us superrechner der atomwaffen
entwicklung dienen es liegt nahe dass
auch china seine spitzen systeme genau
zu diesem zweck einsetzen möchte china
könnte damit also nicht nur mit einem
sondern sogar mit gleich zwei exascale
computersystem seine vormachtstellung
bei der entwicklung von atomwaffen
deutlich ausgebaut haben doch warum
schweigt china so beharrlich und warum
meldet china solche starken top 500
systeme nicht an schon seit einigen
jahren gibt es dazu spekulationen dass
dieses politische gründe haben könnte
und es am zweck der entwicklung von
atomwaffen liegt auf der anderen seite
werden deutlich schwächere top500
rechner von chinesischen unternehmen
angemeldet und so kommen die meisten der
systeme auf der top 500 liste aus china
selbst möglicherweise werden die neuen
infos zu den beiden exaflop
supercomputer aber auch gezielt von
china ans licht gebracht denn die top500
veröffentlichung steht an tesla baut
cyberport und den schnellsten
supercomputer der welt anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren denn auch tesla
mischt im rennen um den schnellsten
computer der welt mit es bleibt also
spannend auch hier praktisch zum science
and future also abonnieren nicht
vergessen das geht hier unter dem video
einfach draufklicken in abo button gibt
es unter jedem video bis dann bleibt
dran